British tanks will soon be rolling into
battle against Russian forces in Ukraine
a landmark moment and a major boost to
Ukrainian Firepower along with British
artillery guns and ammunition the
defense secretary announced the details
in Parliament today's package is an
important increase to Ukraine's
capabilities
it means they can go from existing to
expelling Russian forces from Ukrainian
soil
that back on British soil the UK's own
ability to fight is looking increasingly
feeble the Army already had a shortage
of tanks and artillery all in need of an
upgrade
now a good chunk of that is either in
Ukraine or heading there
in a sign of the gravity of the
situation the head of the army made this
Frank admission to his troops in an
internal video message Sky News has seen
a copy of the transcript
giving away these capabilities will
leave us temporarily weaker as an army
there's no denying it but ensuring
Russia's defeat in Ukraine makes us
safer and as a leading member of NATO
the world's most powerful defensive
Alliance we are protected by the
principle of collective defense
General Sir Patrick Saunders also
stressed the need to modernize the Army
in comments that appeared designed to
put pressure on the new prime minister
for more funds it'll be pointless saying
that the British army could go and fight
against Russia we have next no artillery
next to no tanks next no uh usable
combat vehicles
um you would be sending troops into
Harm's Way where they would suffer
as well as Shock the World Russia's
invasion of Ukraine has demonstrated the
need for strong defenses it's a lesson
the UK surely can't afford to ignore
debraham Sky News